et ce à quoi la question
non mais alors que ça revient à la mode
en fait le mot une source il comme à
ceux delphine la moustache aussi ça vous
ça vous direz vous non mais là car on
dirait que ce fait qu'elle s'est
implanté des sourcils c'est quand même
incroyable
non ça existe voilà les gens font ce
qu'ils font ce qu'ils veulent mais c'est
dommage mais ses deux jeunes fils en le
sourcil son regard sera plus nous a dit
pour laisser pousser les poils nathalie
marquay non pas du tout moi je vous
avais comme un oeuf presque quoi comme
une omelette norma shearer et vers quoi
on l'affecté au laser doit c'est moi
bref oui ah ouais pour sa bonne affaire
oui non pensée voilà certes non sans
doute franchement bien coiffure vous
êtes épiler de partout partout partout
mais il me reste un ticket de métro
maintenant c'est à ces nouvelles contre
auxerre garde et isabelle isabelle us au
carillon est le carnet entier je pensais
à gilles verdez qui va dire mais ce qui
est important c'est l'âme
bien sûr personne alors ça voilà c'est
bien en fait elle elle condamne le
melgueil et le mail gates en fait c'est
le le curieux le merrell games c'est le
prisme masculin c'est à dire
qu'aujourd'hui les femmes certaines
femmes comme c'est cette jeune femme dit
qu'aujourd'hui les femmes se juge qu' à
travers le regard hétérosexuels des
hommes c'est à dire qu'en fait on doit
ces piles et pour personne on doit se
maquiller pour plaire aux hommes on doit
être mon étude dans la dorsale est
maintenant important mais n'est ce pas
halloween on m'expliquer sympa mais donc
du coup et c'est vrai que c'est un
combat et aujourd'hui les nanas veulent
absolument avoir un mono sourcil et
laisser les bras par exemple quel drame
c'est qu'on fait un débat surtout
maintenant ma seule envie de se laisser
poilus qu'elle reste polie mais quel
espace et la démission un temps
d'attenté aux l'évêque lahey les belles
interventions 100 m le point mais c'est
moi c'est pas mon père à mon mari je
montre août ce qui peut penser moi s'il
te plaît à moi c'est vraiment que je
vois ça comme un authentique comme un
oeuf comme comme un oeuf et un ticket de
métro pareil on entend incarner
j'en ai le même match jean digérer le
tout quoi et le tout à huy maintenant
oui c'est vrai le torse le jeu bouctou
mais qui vous a demandé
j'avais envie de m'exprimer sur ce point
si vous êtes mauvais goût ni jeu j'ai
pilé cigogneaux à la cire non non ça
fait trop mal non la somme en jeu à la
crème dessert non c'est pas vrai la
piquante assassin peut un peu débordé
jeudi j'ai tout enlevé c'est pas mal
c'est une liberté quand on touche ça
pique ben oui quoi c'est à dire que
c'est quelqu'un qui donne à la non non
attendez attendez là et là on s'arrête
de petits ça veut dire que jean-pierre
ici ils épient ça c'est un scoop pas
tous partout n'ont pas tous partout il a
pratiqué deux n'ont pas non non non non
non non non
il est alors c'est une école lui ah
ouais donc revenir à ce qu'il dépasse
quoi laisser deviner quoi et palin et
tient les pales dîner à wemmel est
d'accord pour répondre à la question
bouge je suis sûr dans son film sherwood
à répondre à la question moi il aime le
naturel on est exactement
d'ailleurs et plein de pays où les
femmes se laissent sur les bras et la
vie entre autres donc c'est plutôt
pourquoi pas la joie 16 mois je m'épile
tout sauf le boom mais je vais les piles
et bientôt j'ai décidé parce que si je
refais l'unam du réseau d'égout si je
refais du naturisme c'est plus à la mode
ah oui l'épilation combat alors c'est la
mauvaise nouvelle du jour pour les
naturistes
et cette fois là et sans poils voilà si
vous voyez vous sert il non non moi
alors moi je suis battu moi je suis même
pas les torses fois je suis partout
quand je plonge dans la mer on a
l'impression qu'il a une algue c'était
quelqu'un qui avait lancé les 22 carats
de la vigne c'est merci ça il ya dix ans
déjà il ya dix ans déjà 15 degrés merci
à vous et mamie ou parle c'est bon tu
râles mannequin